[Music]
[Music]
hey Outlander fans welcome to Comic Con
for those of you guys who couldn't make
it right now I'm Liana Galera here with
your favorite cat Outlander hi guys it's
so lovely to see you all and I've got to
say you push through quite the drought
Lander this year dry laundry is really
oh no oh my gosh but I've got to know
what has it been like for you guys to
come back to comic-con you've been here
since 2015
Sophie you had another before welcome
little Arlo Comic Con version what is it
like we use it is it a fun experience is
a little daunting it's not I mean you
don't really have time to think about it
we're going to get which from one thing
to the other but great we're going to
figure out on the on the floor and shore
around later yeah yeah leave you there
you guys are finally done in a minute
you guys are finally finished with
season three you got back from South
Africa what was that experience like Oh
South Africa is beautiful what does he
like best about we just make it yes I
know I know we're going to be talking
all about your stuff so much of anything
oh my god it was amazing too wise
amazing we barely worked at all I mean
thank you very much all of Diana was
there oh we got an amazing look at
season three with that trailer I loved
every second of it except for when I saw
that Jamie was kind of closing up to
someone else we're not gonna really talk
about that part um who would you cozy up
with you never do that I like to Ross's
book trailer
what
what was your guys's favorite part of
the season 3 trailer because I know that
mine was a familiar little bell the
print shop what was your staff it will
be very less scene of episode 4 broke my
heart okay what happens are we going to
have to wait until we have that epic
Claire and Jamie reunion 20 years I
believe yeah I think it's a 20 year we
decided we were going to film the entire
season in real time so we're really only
a year into Boston Sophie's very
premature she's really matured very well
oh amazing how much he can do and you
spend a lot my age range we spend a lot
of time apart so of course because I was
able oh Claire returns back to to Frank
boo hiss and Jamie goes off to die but I
think you know obviously there's some
some great episodes there and there will
be a little wait but I think it's worth
yeah I think it's definitely the way to
have constructed it it's you know I
don't think you're going to feel that
it's as long because I think you know
you get so invested in Jamie's story and
what he's gone through you see a lot of
Claire and Frank and Brianna and it's
just it's really exciting you know I
love that we got to see a little bit of
Frank and Claire's Boston home that is a
set I'm nice apart it is so nice we're
going to be having a little sneak peek
for you guys on ET coming up soon a tour
of your home but what was it like for
you guys to be able to play out those
flashback scenes and really get into
Clair and Frank's dynamic as sophie with
a baby or as free what was it like to be
able to play out that flashback dynamic
and really fill in the blanks it was
great I think you know obviously there's
there's a huge chunks of time that
weren't really documented or you know
see we did talk a lot about well what do
you think their everyday life is and we
try to make
you know it as real as possible for
ourselves about what that dynamic inside
the home would be but it's a great it's
such a beautiful complicated story and
the relationship is so rich it was
really fun to play it yeah I know it was
I mean that some one of the nice things
about the show has been a chance to dig
into that relationship a bit more and
yeah I mean I guess we tried to make it
sort of as complicated as real a
marriage as possible as they try and you
know they try and make this quite
complicated situation obviously being
bring up a child at someone else's yeah
I think it's paid off there so people in
therapy we all do it Dan I've got to say
Voyager was my favorite book it's such
an ambitious project to go from book to
screen when you were talking Marilyn
you're talking with Ron what was the one
thing that you personally wanted to see
from your books come to life see from
that particular book you made yeah yeah
well multiple things arch near Kristen
has always been one of my favorite parts
yeah he'll water is my second favorite
I'd say yes the parks where Jamie is
actually living yet more or less a
day-to-day thing
Clara and Franco their story is a
backdrop in the main in the book and we
just revisited in flashbacks because at
that point you know Claire is telling it
to Brianna and so as being lived
backwards but Jamie's thread in that
story is the one that's moving forward
so we're living it with him through his
various adventures and so forth
that's in the books a little bit more
closer than personal we got to talk
about the print shop scene we've got to
talk about it when you guys first read
that scene what was your initial
reaction well we're not saying anything
cos we're trying to give away too much
but enough same as me
its usual okay well basically no one
else here right nobody it's so so so
much anticipated I think for ourselves
and also for the fans and you know we
wanted to do it justice it's like one of
those scenes or one of those moments in
the
book that I think you know we want to
serve Diana's writing and but so much
happens before that it really it all
builds up to that point when they meet -
it just raises the tension of mistakes
and I mean it was nice to work with you
again yeah no it was great and you know
I think Matt did a great adaptation and
that's that episode was great but I
think you know you you want to approach
it with just you know each of these
characters mean for Jaime it was it was
a totally different thing he had no idea
what was you know he had no preconceived
notions of what that day was going to
bring but for Clare there's such a
build-up and there's such a you know an
expectation and I'm sure she ran through
a thousand different scenarios of what
exactly what happened but it was really
fun to play and yeah I think I think it
ended up being really sweet I haven't
seen it okay if we got the honesty of
approval though and I got the only
person who's seen it what what was your
thoughts well you know that mind about
how he felt he fainted gracefully for
such a large man yeah he actually did
about 14 times in a row Sophie it was so
interesting we first met Bree in season
2 to see that she had a naturally
strained relationship with Clare what
was it like for you two to be able to
kind of fill in those blanks and go back
and really figure out why it is that
they didn't quite get along yeah well I
think that's something that in the book
isn't quite as prominent I think we
really did lay on sick that kind of
20-year tension but kind I talked about
it before and we just wanted to make
sure that that came from something so it
wasn't just kind of really coming across
as bratty or Clare coming across was
hiding something you knows like for her
own gain and it's just working on that
relationship between the two of them and
season three is nice because you kind of
get to the point where Bree really
understands my clothes in this
information actually that she did it
from a very selfless point of view and I
think also is that thing of Bree really
looks up to Clare I mean we see her as a
surgeon now in the 60s and
it's just really aspirational for a
woman 60s through daughter to be able to
kind of look up and and see that so I
think she then understands like I was
absent in the workplace as well so yeah
hey get over it and for all your fans
who are wondering right now rick is
actually on a panel right now so he's
off representing Outlander on a
comic-con panel right now they're
dressed on like the Sophie what can you
tease about Roger and Brees on-screen
dynamics because fans fell in love with
their chemistry last year yeah well I
think the thing again rich and I talked
about was those things before in the
book their relationship kind of moves
quite quickly so I think we wanted to
give the fans something to root for with
Roger and Bree and every time they get
closer they also get torn apart by equal
measures it is kind of that back and
forth between the two of them so sort of
relationship tension but yeah well why
is the kiss on the trailer so I guess
laughs I went into one thing that you
want Outlander fans to know before they
tune in to season three it's really sad
yeah I wanna do some yeah I don't know I
mean this you make us wait all this time
I'm never just gonna take your heart
all right you but there's also new
beginnings as well you know in stocks
and new characters so it really is a
rollercoaster business lastly when I
called out to you amazing fans for
questions you gave me so many great ones
overwhelmingly they wanted me to do two
things one they wanted me to give Sam a
hug on behalf of the fandom oh thank you
so I'm probably fine okay you know that
I hug you every time ah - they wanted to
know what you smell like so Katrina I'll
let you answer that one summer water
oh you born you bore baby are you going
on
and uh whiskey with some snowdrop ya
know dresses thank you guys so much for
stopping by stamina yeah called
Outlander fans to you thank you very
much guys make sure you tune in to
season three of Outlander keep watching
ET Facebook page like subscribe comment
all that good stuff thank you so much
take a bye guys bye